The EHR SQL dataset consists of 24,000 questions to SQL pairs, frequently asked on structured EHR data.
The questions were collected from a poll conducted at a university hospital and more than 200 hospital staff, including doctors, nurses, insurance review staff, infection control staff, and more participated in the poll.
The label SQL queries are linked to two open source EHR databases, Mimic 3 and EICU.
The unique challenges of the dataset are, first, we have a wide range of real-world questions frequently asked on structured EHR data.
From retrieving a patient's test results, to summing of a patient's total hospital cost, and calculating the survival rate of a certain group of patients, the questions in the dataset reflect the diverse needs of staff in the hospital.
Second, time is very important in healthcare.
To reflect that, we templatize time and combine them with the questions to make the data set more realistic.
Lastly, we have unanswerable questions that were collected together from the poll.
The questions were unanswerable because they were either ambiguous or went beyond the database schemas.
These questions are later used to test the trustworthiness of text to SQL models.